hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's you want to know something
rather silly it's currently nine o'clock
and I am incredibly tired I am an old
old man at this point I'm still on
Cincinnati time and that's not really an
excuse I'm tired and I want to go to bed
at 9 o'clock but I'm pushing through it
because I need to play more five nights
at candy's and Seaworth is gonna take me
so he met Jojo last time that was really
fun except for I was horrible and stuff
but Jonah's gonna be cool and I wonder
if pang goos gonna come out of hiding
properly
hello it's me marki MooMoo oh why okay
of what uh hello
looks like you're doing a fine job I
mean you're still here yeah you're
already like practically as good as the
last card we had except of course you
know got fired yet but yeah yeah kind of
damaged one of the animatronics during
shift I mean you wouldn't do that would
you
anyway um I guess he went a little crazy
you know he's alone at the dark each
night you know that character that the
kids can run you know blank I think wait
this guy yeah I always really liked that
one yeah brilliant concept yeah yeah his
suit is made out of some special plastic
stuff I think that the kids can come in
and you know grab a crayon and start
drawing on his head or his arms I as
some of the others here he looks a bit
scary
a security guard thing we tried our best
to fix him but arch them like his left
hand and the back of his head are still
missing but the kids don't really seem
to mind it you know so it's not a major
issue yeah from what we can tell his
head got a real beating so he might act
a little strange
like she sometimes tried to get into the
office through the window even managed
to crack the glass slightly he leaves
the drawing room he shut the window door
so he doesn't push glass those old ones
couldn't really see glass very well
okay um by the way we're expecting more
customers over the course of the next
days so next week we may need you on the
base shift to say you're up for it um
well anyway have a good night okay
nothing like working 24 hours wall crazy
animatronics to try and help me and are
you trying to tell me that one of the
animatronics has brain damage because
that seems a little unplug
I mean I'm totally on board with the
living animatronic and I don't know what
the hell this thing is supposed to be ah
that's fun that's full of fun I can't
wait to have fun with that later when
I'm dying he's strangling me lots of fun
knowing Nando's know that so blank is
supposed to come through my windows oh
whoa my friend
Oh God huh how quick was that gonna kill
me uh I need to pay more attention I'm
looking in too much in the environment I
should I should understand five nights
anything you don't pay attention to the
environment you just try to survive by
Jojo hello Momo Oh God blankie Blank
he is my least favorite he's in the room
with where I'm on the wall and when he
gets here I'm gonna be splattered all
over the walls once again not sexually I
want to reiterate that as much as
possible nothing I'm saying in this
circumstance could be misconstrued as
sexual hi Jojo you're a little closer
than I anticipated
so a bow
goddamn your actor
I got Anna Chapman to teacher you okay
it's going well I'm happy about my life
and everything that I'm doing this job
is worth it I feel safe
has he moved yet no hmm Oh judge is
already on the way back
good I was wondering when I was gonna
have company it's almost a damn shame
I'm so good at this game i'm never gonna
experience another jump-scare as long as
i live because I'm so damn
oh hi Joe Joe all right good oh the
music stopped just as I was feeling more
comfortable about my environment thank
you oh hi is that Joe Joe better be now
so far so good
hello hi you're not still wondering who
you are I don't want to call you mom oh
but it's okay boy oh he gone he gone he
gone I don't know if Cindy your candy
goes to the left or right I don't think
I want it yeah yeah good god I do not
want to die from a Joe Joe to the face
Nora Momo Nora blankie blue I know
there's not those real names but hey I
don't care at the moment of triumph very
I'm a tired old man who's not used to
this animatronic hell anybody else want
to come after me
you know I say that I'm good at this
game but I know I'm gonna get plenty of
deaths when night 4 & 5 roll around whoa
whoa that don't okay Oh God [ __ ] you
okay that was all as a so bad I
shouldn't have spoken so soon why did I
get my blood all over the other person's
newspaper it prepare if you know didn't
bother to read all the other texts
around there because that would have
been cool too let's try again this time
with a little more little you know but
if available my favourite quality what
was I supposed to do about that Blanc
came down pretty quickly if that is
really his name see you guys back at
night three like I didn't even have time
to react he was kind of there and gone
not cool
oh hey there is no okay go hey how's
goin friend I how's it going friend okay
good to know that everyone's back in a
jiffy right so should I be worried
bad blanky Moo I mean blanky blue seems
to be worried about me considering how
deeply is staring into my eyes and
where'd Momo go huh I want to have a
private moment with Momo maybe I should
just keep the middle window closed when
he steps out because they just realize
this kind of a quick jump from him to go
straight to my window probably not gonna
be the best idea probably not gonna be
the best idea at all I mean other than
checking the side doors on the Reg
really okay maybe it's one of those
situations where you're not supposed to
look at it very tightly closely not
tightly once again nothing I'm saying
can be misconstrued as sexual just cuz
I'm wearing my awesome Reptar sleeveless
shirt in case you were all wondering and
the reason I'm wearing it is because I
have been climbing
I've got out cheese on my fingers all of
my fingers had been out debated okay so
I'm gonna close that just in case I
don't know if that's gonna do anything
for me all I know is that's gonna chew
up a lot of power usually have that
power to spare
maybe I'll get a Hindi whoo I mean I can
turn it off on the Reg and let die down
then put it back on that would chew a
little less power i guess i don't know i
don't know the stratagems it's true dude
use well I heard a pitter-patter of some
fede Wheaties no one hurts their feet
Wheaties on anything just like my fingy
wing is being all out sure hey so what
was the cause of that
what was the cause of that misconstrued
a Gration and who the hell are looking
at me through what camera oh this is you
okay it's Joe Joe Hey Joe Joe Joe
go get your friend Momo we'll have a
good old time so that must have been a
good strategy I mean I'm assuming later
on it's gonna be even quicker maybe not
now linkie who doesn't want to mess with
me I've been climbing and working out
look at all my math skills I'm so
getting fit I'm still a big blob of flab
I saw that thank you
I'm still a big old gelatinous blob of
flat but soon I'll be cut like it like a
diamond or oh hey poochie's don't sneak
up on me like that there's like no way
anticipation of when you're gonna be
there son of a biscuit son of a pooper
son of a pooper duper have a booper
dooper day okay so I guess Momo's just
doesn't want to play anymore
okay everybody mama what did you play
hey how's it goin double nerd be talkin
hey mama
mummy moomer someone told me that there
was actually uh me as an animatronic in
this game or someone made fan art of it
I saw a picture of me as an animal oh I
don't know what to do about you
hand goos out why is Pangu
that's cool I think he's adorable I
wonder what the death screen from him
looks like probably cute and awesome
or horrifying you know JoJo's coming
down justice to be here soon
Oh Oh JoJo's here all right Jojo was
here
so where did little little little
biscuit oh he's so cute
oh he just wants to go to the bathroom
Oh what an adorable Oh what an adorable
little nightmare oh he's going to murder
my face off but I'm not - oh hey Wow
Momo you're moving I did not know that
was something I should be worried about
okay good
um gonna get you anything you don't have
any eyeballs so I don't know if you're
staring at me from the darkness but I
can only assume it's a lovingly long
gaze Hey so Pangu and Momo are the only
people that I'm not entirely sure what
they do but I think I'm gonna be okay I
mean it's 5:00 a.m. what could possibly
go wrong I'm less than an hour away from
retirement I'm gonna have a great time
blanks all done things cool everything's
coming up my grave
oh god he's getting closer do I judge is
this is a problem just being he is gonna
be staring at me from the blankness and
I'm not gonna know if he's coming or not
and I'm pretty sure that's all of them
okay I'm gonna preemptively close that
door just in case maybe close that to
maybe this one down would be a good idea
all right this till the Sun sets that's
prime not get a good idea but why not
allow a blast out some power here too
hey it ain't nothing I got power for
days bruh power for days where did
Penghu go well this isn't a good sign I
seem to be using up everything I could
pose didn't matter I'm a winner
nonetheless good for me okie dokie
so I wonder what's next little poppy
baby loading the feed where we got for
me to stand Betty boo san friend oh
we're so late at night
what what did a please come in Oh
having a trouble there
you got a crick in the neck I can come
by and help you out apparently semester
investigation came out on those bloody
Robo pieces hey what are you doing so
close
well there you have it then there's that
so that was the thing
so anyway ah it's getting interesting
it's really interesting like by far this
probably is the one that's trying to be
the most faithful recreation of five
days of reading will not recreation but
adding on to the universe in its own way
in the same theme you know what I mean I
don't know if that means it's the best I
don't want to say once the best or the
other although one night at flumpty's is
really really cool so I'll let you guys
be the judge so thank you everybody so
much for watching I'm going to go to bed
soon after I added this so thanks again
everybody
I will go off to sleepy by and my old
man chair wrapped up in a blanket
remembering how those damn cakes need to
stay off my lawn anyway so thanks again
everybody and as always I'll see you in
the next video
ah